when Toy Story debuted in theaters in
1995 it was a groundbreaking achievement
the completely computer animated feature
was the first of its kind breaking away
from traditional 2D animation equally
Toy Story was the first film produced by
Pixar which has become one of the most
dominant Studios when it comes to
animated films the story of Woody birds
and all of their toy friends has created
a legacy that is still prominent today
with a spin-off film Lightyear being
released in 2022 and Toy Story 5 in the
early stages of development an entire
generation grew up watching the diverse
collection of animated toys Bond and
grow over 25 years audiences kept a soft
spot for the iconic franchise akin to
how the human boy Andy treated his
beloved toys spanning from 1995 to 2019
Pixar's headlining franchise has grown
to become one of the highest grossing
animated franchises of all time there is
no doubt the Toy Story quadrilogy is one
of the most successful four-part
collections ever made